valentine's Day is all about celebrating
all kinds of love love between spouses
love toward relatives and as we found
out this week love can last through the
years even after a short but meaningful
encounter Landman arrived in San
Francisco Thursday remembering a time 56
years ago when she was a Peace Corps
volunteer in Abaddonn Iran I pulled out
some of my student pictures from many
years ago that was 1964 and Iran Murphy
has spent much of her life remembering
that time too she was 10 years old when
Miss Mina then a Peace Corps volunteer
taught school she made the whole class
fall in love with the US I just talked
to my older sister and she was sending
me all you did when you came home he
said miss Mino this miss Mina that
Murphy learned English from Mina and
lessons about Western culture that would
make immigrating nine years later to
California easier even though so much
had changed the Peace Corps pulled out
in 1972 is the friendship between Iran
and the u.s. disintegrated but not
Murphy's memory of Mina my mom just kept
talking about Miss Mina
by the time Murphy Sun Rosten was an
adult and completed his own Peace Corps
mission to China in 2012 he'd heard
enough this is you know the information
age if you want to find someone you can
find them and I just told her just go do
it why not with the help of the Internet
and the Peace Corps I'm beyond excited
I'm a little nervous I'm about to tear
up they agreed to meet again in San
Francisco yesterday
[Music]
the Peace Corps was allowed to serve in
Iran only 14 years this is lynn mina and
iran Murphy had the privilege of being
part of that brief moment in history
since 1965 in it and the lasting legacy
of the Peace Corps just it's just
wonderful to think about that how many
times have you met someone and had an
encounter an impact and like that of
teaching and remembering at that age
yeah really
you